oh it's this girl usury I'm sandy Wexler  can we talk somewhere I'm a talent  manager sandy was not a big shiny the  tiny shot but you never forgotten  anything of the big laugh it's like why  are you fake laughing it's Eddie Murphy  funny  get this kid keep him at a party and you  think no one even invited this guy I've  got the way which way to move we do know  he dressed like your grandfather whoa  whoa at the table manners of a horse  Daniel Gators all dead yeah but great  manager you are a cool wet Ferrari how  do you make you know everybody and never  worry about yourself  that's what I do  my agent is business for the manager of  salmon I will always do what's best for  my client  that was going to be anybody I'd be  hervana well you got me  you can't stop a shooting star I'm  scientist approving but we gotta get to  work now why the lights out he's leaning  on the light switch  no I'm not what that wasn't me  what isn't it from the top bye-bye  you